[Music]
chuck we're back
okay and let's talk about spaceship heat
shields
yes and do you know why they exist
to stop phasers from penetrating the
ship's hull
i didn't say
i that's a different kind of shield oh
my heat shield
damn not phaser shields oh man
damn oh you don't want to hang around
anymore okay
ordinary heat shields okay you've always
seen
you've heard about it you've read about
it and you know what they're for
um i would guess because it gets
hot so they're going to shield you
from the heat okay that's not their
purpose
what yeah that's not that's not why they
exist
well that's a very deceptive name
i thought about that that's right yeah
that's an
extremely deceptive name
it implies that you're gonna get hot and
burn up so you have to protect yourself
from it
until you put in these shields so that
you don't die so why is nasa toying with
my emotions like this
this because now you care because the
astronauts is living fleshy things
inside the capsule
right okay so if it's not to stop me
from burning up and dying
what's it for okay so here it is ready
you need heat shields because
any object in orbit is going
especially low earth orbit it's going 18
000
miles an hour right okay that's right
that's fast so
if you do the math that's like five
miles per second second
eight kilometers a second all right so
that's fast well if you're going that
fast in any other situation you'd put on
the brakes
right you would find some way to slow
down
well spacecraft don't also
carry fuel to slow down with
no retro rockets no retro rockets now
they do
well no not really no well well it
depends wait hold on
when they're coming back to earth no
retro rockets okay still no retro rocks
still not retro retract
so but you're right it would be called
retro rocket so whatever here i'm going
so fast let me
flip the engine the other way or point
the nozzle
and blow exhaust opposite the direction
i'm going that will slow me down
okay if we had that
that's all you'd have to do to come out
of orbit is
blow exhaust out the other direction
until you have zero velocity
pop a parachute and then glide down to
earth
yeah like like in a ship like all
engines reverse you know and you see the
propeller stop and go
opposite directions correct correct okay
that's all you'd have to do
but to carry the
fuel that you're not going to use until
you want to come out of orbit
you that takes fuel to put the fuel that
you're not burning and so
we said we're not going to do this
because we don't have to
let's take all of this kinetic energy
this energy of motion and let the
atmosphere burn it off let the
atmosphere
sweep it away so we they're called heat
shields but you know what they are
they're
aerobraking it's an aerobraking system
ah-ha you want this
because you intentionally didn't bring
fuel or breaks to slow you down
so you use air to do it
so what do they do here's the capsule in
orbit moving real fast
okay and it's set up in such a way that
the bottom section
uh it'll always sort of dangle with that
coming first
and it's it's this big blunt thing that
plows into the atmosphere the atmosphere
is i'm not going to want to let you do
that
but i'm coming through anyway there's
not aerodynamic at all
it's it's totally not well it's not an
ability that it's not going to be
turbulent
um it'll stability come through but
right you are you want to maximize this
resistance
and in so doing you heat up the bottom
side of the craft
where does the energy come from that's
heating the bottom of the craft
the air friction i know but
okay what was the original source of
that energy
what do you mean it was your speed of
the crash oh that's right the craft
itself
flying in at 18 000 miles a minute thank
you thank you
we got to get rid of that energy somehow
so
here it comes all right let us come down
and work our way into the atmosphere
and in the upper layers there's not as
much air molecules
but there it is and you get sort of
shock waves and friction
and all manner of other sort of
communicating molecules
all right and that speed becomes heat
energy the kinetic energy becomes heat
energy now
if it only becomes heat energy that's
not good enough because then you'll
still burn up
you've got to whisk away that heat
energy so
right okay send it somewhere else
get it out of here so in the old days
and even in many
modern capsules the quote heat shields
are onion layers of burnable substance
oh so they are heating up
and then they're peeling away they're
peeling away so the
so all the heat is
actually like wicking like moisturizing
like that
i like that analogy you're wicking away
the heat and every time you do this the
thing is slowing down and continues to
slow down
and depending on how much kinetic energy
you have add on a few more layers
okay when they came back from the moon
they re-entered the atmosphere at a
higher speed
than just coming out of low earth orbit
so
the the mooncrafts coming back had more
heat shield layers
than the other spacecraft wow
that's by the way it's aerobraking
that's what it is ingenious
it is com and it's blunt and it's low
tech and it worked every time
i don't know who thought of that but
that guy should have got a doughnut
somebody was really thinking i mean yeah
yeah and it works and it and it works
every time
so so it's so it's i think the the
correct word is it ablates
ablate so you're saying whisking it
ablates and so and it goes away
and when you're done and you have low
enough speed then you deploy your
parachute
and you just dip dip in that is genius
there is a sci-fi movie where they are
in orbit around some planet i think
it might be mars but it's some planet i
don't remember which
and they're on some stable orbiting
platform
but there's one of these platforms that
sort of rotates with
the rotating planet okay and a guy
falls off the platform towards the
planet
and that's bad and you see and then he
goes down and then you see him
disappear in a puff of smoke no
no no just because you're entering an
atmosphere doesn't mean you're gonna
burn up
right the burning up is not an inherent
feature of passing through an atmosphere
the burning up comes from getting rid of
the speed you had
to maintain 18 000 miles an hour when we
landed on the moon
moon's got no atmosphere right how do
you get a soft landing there
can't use a parachute can't use
aerobraking
they needed retro rockets got to have
retro rockets yeah yep
there it is mars has a thin atmosphere
so that one had parachute big parachute
plus retro rockets plus aerobraking
all three to get the rovers on mars oh
you drop a trampoline
thank you well i'll bring that up at the
next nasa meeting okay
chuck knight says trampoline
[Laughter]
why did it take us five days to land on
the moon
[Laughter]
yeah if it's a perfect trampoline it
will never stop it'll never dissipate
the energy it'll just keep bouncing
right you want it to
the energy has to dissipate somehow
it'll heat up the springs
the energy can't just disappear it has
to
transmute into some other form and then
get whisked away as you said
so you should i think you should always
think of heat shields as
aerobraking systems rather than oh you
need this otherwise you'll burn up no
you need it otherwise you'll crash
that's so cool and that's really cool
oh and uh in the movie 2010
ostensibly the sequel to 2001 they came
to jupiter
and they aerobraked around jupiter that
some really good
visual effects for the day and the
inside the craft is saying
oh wow this is i wish i could see this
from the outside this aerobraking
basically any spacecraft with heat
shields coming through an atmosphere
is error breaking anytime so that was
not some new thing it was
portrayed as some new innovative concept
but of course we do that
all the time in fact there are
spacecraft that come into mars
and their orbit is highly elongated
that's a hot uh that's a higher energy
orbit and they want to sort of
circularize it
so when it dips down closer to the
atmosphere it makes sure
that the atmosphere slows it down a
little bit that eats some of the energy
and you can circularize in orbit on
purpose that way
so they just kind of like skipping rocks
skipping rocks
i like that i like that that's cool so
there you go chuck
i think of it as error breaking not
heat shields for the future very nice do
not try this on earth that's all i can
say
please don't try this on earth but that
is a really cool concept and if you fall
out of your spaceship
and and fall towards a planet uh if you
die
it won't have to be because you burned
up
right it'll just be because you hit the
plant
right either way that dude was gonna die
all right chuck chuck co-host always a
pleasure
all right neil degrasse tyson as always
keep looking up
[Music]
you